hey guys den and Mary here at TGS 2016
and we've just gotten back from the show
floor where Mary you put on a
PlayStation VR and you went down
Louisiana way to the Baker family to New
in the new resident evil 7 demo yeah
biohazard again with a new demo and I
always end up playing scary ones well I
mean I'm Way too scared so I can't do it
so how did you find the VR in this one
yes the first one it's you know they're
getting better with it this demo is
pretty frightening there's like one of
the the mother of the Baker family had
the lantern and she's chasing me I'm
trying to get away from her and hiding I
found that the VR is getting much better
than in previous the previous demo way
more about movement of your head then
turning up the stick which can really
separate you and take you out of the
game I enjoyed there's this moment where
you have to hide behind a box and I
enjoy cleaning my head out ever so
slightly to see her yes that's really
interesting because I that's what I feel
like makes me either that really
interesting new thing is you interacting
with that whole world so I'm glad that
they're implementing it really know
completely illusion that you are there
and when she lists the lantern I found
myself shrinking down to to not be seen
so those things are really really
helping it the atmosphere the the sounds
oh you know there's this part we have to
get into between the walls and your
whole you're hugging the walls and I
felt that like the claustrophobic
absolutely i mean they do a really good
job of really creating this illusion
that you're in these people's houses and
you're scared and it's it's really grill
she definitely definitely was scared
there any shortcomings to this one do
you think yeah you know i would always
say when it comes to be our it's hard
when anyone touches you yes because i
know i'm not being touched in real life
and I can sense that so at the very end
of the demo the father kind of grabs the
back of my head and I leaned back
instinctively because I don't want him
to do that and I went through his hands
like a ghost yeah I could see the back
of his hand I mean that kind of really
breaks the illusion I would prefer them
to not it's almost like going to a
haunted house get really close but don't
yeah yeah what we were talking to
someone and they were saying the way
they get through scary VR experiences is
to kind of push through the environment
to like see if there's anything on the
other side
I'd which is you know a short coming but
also something that I think could be
kind of cool yeah see behind the scenes
of like what you're playing xing it's
not fully there yet those kinds of
things make me nervous but in terms of
creating a very scary atmosphere in
terms of giving me the drive to get out
and we want to move forward in the game
they did some really cool stuff there
there was a really simple puzzle I'm
curious to see I hope they have a more
intricate puzzles down the road and
there was like a structure and I had to
kind of form it into a spider yep uh but
you know I see elements thereof a good
rezi game yeah I speak for all of us why
I want this to be good so I have high
hopes sounds like Mary's cane I'm
certainly came but I'm Way too scared to
play and for everything else tgs related
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot